5 146 tonnes c'est notre chiffre du jour
et il s'agit de la quantité de masques à
usage unique consommé chaque jour par
les 65 millions de français en âge de le
mettre
cet accessoire est devenu incontournable
dans notre quotidien depuis le 20
juillet dernier et l'obligation de le
porter dans tous les espaces publics
clos pour essayer de lui donner une
seconde vie des initiatives se
multiplient et même à côté de chez nous
direction joué les tours où un couple de
pharmaciens a décidé de s'attaquer ce
nouveau déchets aurélie renault donc là
voilà c'est à peu près la collecte
depuis un mois qu'on a donc c'est
principalement les entreprises qui nous
apporte leur masque derrière la
pharmacie une vingtaine de sacs
poubelles remplis de masques
chirurgicaux usagers dans quelques jours
les pharmaciens livreront eux mêmes
leurs collectes dans une entreprise de
châtellerault spécialiste du recyclage
les masques deviendront de la matière
plastique un soir mon époux va regarder
un truc sur le recyclage des masques et
ça nous a vraiment plu de style urbain
en fait depuis le début on dit que c'est
pas valorisables qui ont peu que les
brûler et que là en fait il ya une
solution innovante et les technologiques
le bouche à oreille fonctionne et les
particuliers eux aussi profitent du
point de collecte improvisé et il a même
des patients qu'on connaît pas qui
viennent
dedans dehors je suis sûr de
joué-lès-tours de tournoi on a eu un
appel d'une dame ci qui est venu que
pour ça déposé à ces masques c'est très
facile à faire et il faudrait qu
effectivement les points de collecte
soit soit plus étendu désormais le
recyclage s'organise dans les communes
de tours métropole des bornes de
collecte commence à être installé comme
ici à rochecorbon et c'est l'entreprise
tri 37 qui sera chargée du ramassage des
bornes plastique
après on va les stocker pendant au moins
trois jours pour la première des
combines des contaminations et puis
ensuite on va les massifier les emmener
vers le centre de traitement
d'un côté les masque en tissu de l'autre
les masques à usage unique les bornes
plastique peuvent contenir jusqu'à 1800
masque soit l'équivalent de 8 kg de
déchets elles seront déployées dans les
halls de mairies les écoles et les
déchetteries aujourd'hui une centaine de
points va être mis en place dans les
jours qui viennent et à terme
certainement on en aura 200 300 400 les
masques seront ensuite valorisées par
neutralisent une start-up tourangelle
qui a fédéré autour d'elle une dizaine
d'entreprises de recyclage isolant pour
le bâtiment textile polaire les masques
recyclé intégreront aussi la plasturgie
exemple avec les équipementiers
automobiles sur le principe de
l'extrusion pour pouvoir créer en fait
des objets des tableaux de bord des
clignotants des pare-chocs six tours
métropole arrive à collecter au moins
80% des masques portés par les habitants
des 22 communes neutralisent pourrait
alors recycler près de 80 tonnes de
déchets chaque mois